IS HIGHLY WHEN YOU CALL THE-
BURKE HERE. WHEN IS THERE AN-
GRAYSON. CARILLO CALDERON
MULLIN. PETRIE-NORRIS WORK HERE
RIVAS. THEY ARE TOLD HERE. WE
HAVE CORMAY HAVE A QUORUM I
APOLOGIZE IN LATE EVERYBODY
GOOD MORNING AND WELCOME
TODAY'S HEARING ON ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON REVENUE AND
TAXATION WE ARE STILL REQUIRING
THAT MASS BE WARNED WEATHER
HERE IN THE ROOM OR AT THE
VIDEO CONFERENCINGSITE IF YOU
DO NOT HAVE A MASS WE CAN
PROVIDE ONE FOR YOU. WE HAVE A
FEW DIFFERENT OPTIONS FOR
WITNESS TESTIMONY TODAY IF ANY
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC HERE IN
THE ROOM WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFYING TO BILL PLEASE RAISE
YOUR HAND AND I WILL ASK YOU TO
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE AT THAT
TIME. I WOULD ASK THE PUBLIC
NOT TO TOUCH THE MICROPHONE.
YOU CAN EXIT THE HEARING ROOM
ONCE YOU ARE DONE TESTIFYING OR
RETURN TO YOUR SEAT. WILL ALSO
BE USING A MODERATED TELEPHONE
SERVICE THROUGH WHICH ANY
WITNESS CAN TESTIFY ON A BILL.
THE CALL IN NUMBER FOR THIS
HEARING IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN.
SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN AND THE ACCESS CODE IS
ONE THREE ONE. FIVE FOUR. TWO
ZERO TWO. YOU CAN ALSO FIND
THIS NUMBER ON THE ASSEMBLY
REVENUE AND TAXATION COMMITTEE
WEBSITE AS WELL AS ON YOUR TV
SCREEN. IF YOU ARE CALLING IN
PLEASE PLAN TO DO SO AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE AS WE ONLY HAVE ONE
BILL ON TODAY'S AGENDA. IF YOU
ARE CALLING IN PLEASE ELIMINATE
ALL BACKGROUND NOISE THIS
INCLUDES MEETING OF FIVE STREAM
BROADCAST IN YOUR SMART DEVICES
TO REDUCE. SOUND DISTORTION. IF
YOU HAVE ANY PROBLEMS WITH THE
MODERATED PHONE SERVICE YOU CAN
CALL THE COMMITTEE AT NINE ONE
SIX. THREE ONE NINE TWO ZERO
NINE EIGHT AND MY STAFF WILL BE
THERE TO HELP YOU. I ALSO WANT
TO NOTE THAT WE ARE ACCEPTING
WRITTEN TESTIMONY TO THE
POSITION LETTER PORTAL ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. NOW WE
HAVE A FEW ADDITIONAL
HOUSEKEEPING I ANNOUNCEMENTS
FOR THE BILL BEING TAKEN UP
TODAY WE WILL TAKE NO MORE THAN
TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. AND TWO PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION OR WITH
CONCERNS. BUSINESSES LOVE TWO
MINUTES EACH TO PROVIDE THEIR
TESTIMONY. ALL SUBSEQUENT
WITNESSES SHOULD STATE THEIR
NAME THEIR ORGANIZATION AND
THEIR POSITION ON THE BILL
ONLY. FINALLY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LEVINE HAS BEEN REPLACED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CARILLO FOR
THIS HEARING ONLY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MEANS HAS BEEN REPLACED
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERON FOR
THIS HEARING ONLY. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GREAT HAS BEEN REPLACED
BY THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER HIS
ARIAN FOR THIS HEARING ONLY.
SINCE WE HAVE A QUORUM
ESTABLISHED. WITH THAT SENATOR
PORTANTINO SB ONE FORTY FOUR
ITEM NUMBER ONE WHEN YOU'RE
READY. THANK YOU MEDICARE
MEMBERS I DON'T THINK IT MAKES
SENSE WELL THEN I DON'T THINK
HIKES ON THERE NOW IT IS NOW IT
IS THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS FOR HAVING THISSPECIAL
HEARING TO HEAR SB ONE FOUR
FOUR I WANT TO BEGIN BY
THANKING THE CHAIR AND STAFF.
FOR WORKING OVER THE WEEKEND TO
GET US TO THIS POINT AND I ALSO
WANT TO GIVE A SPECIAL
RECOGNITION TO BOTH OF THE
CHAIR AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CARILLO FOR WORKING TO BRING SB
ONE FOUR FOUR TO THE POINT
WE'RE AT TODAY APPRECIATE
COLLABORATION IT'S- WONDERFUL
FOR THE SENATE IN THE ASSEMBLY
TO WORK SO WELL TOGETHER ON AN
IMPORTANT ISSUE FOR THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. AND I KNOW MANY
OF THE GOALS THAT ARE IN THE
BILL OR WERE IMPORTANT TO BOTH
OF YOU SO JUST WANT TO EXTEND A
PERSONAL THANK YOU- SB ONE FOUR
FOUR EXPANDS THE FILM AND
TELEVISION TAX CREDIT PROGRAM
WITH AN EMPHASIS ON
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENT AND
WORKFORCE DIVERSITY. ARE
SIGNIFICANTLY THE BILL EXPANDS
THE EXISTING TAX CREDIT BY
NINETY MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
NEXT TWO YEARS THAT'S A
TESTAMENT TO THE SUCCESS OF THE
PRIOR TAX CREDITS THAT WE
NEEDED TO INJECT MORE RESOURCES
INTO A THREE POINT OUT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAVE THE FUNDING
NECESSARY TO ATTRACT AND KEEP.
NOT FILM FOR. IN CALIFORNIA. AS
YOU KNOW THIS IS A CORE
INDUSTRY- ANNA STORK INDUSTRY.
FOR OUR STATE AND IT'S A SOURCE
OF PRIDE AND FRANKLY. MILLIONS
OF PEOPLE HAVE MOVED TO
CALIFORNIA SPECIFICALLY TO WORK
IN THIS INDUSTRY AND I WAS ONE
OF THEM- THIS. CREDIT THIS BILL
ALSO INCLUDES. AND FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS FOR A NEW FILM
INFRASTRUCTURE CREDIT TO
ENCOURAGE INVESTMENT IN STUDIOS
AND SOUND STAGES IN CALIFORNIA
AGAIN. A CREATURE OF THE PRIOR
SUCCESS OF THE CURRENT TAX
CREDITS IS WE'VE RUN OUT OF
CAPACITY. AND SO WE BUILD MORE
SOUND STAGES NOT ONLY WE HAVE
MORE CURRENT PRODUCTIONS TODAY
BUT WE'LL HAVE MORE PRODUCTIONS
FOR DECADES SO. CAPACITY LEADS
TO MORE JOBS WHICH IS ALSO AN
ECONOMIC DRIVER IN SOMETHING
IMPORTANT TO. EVERYONE IN THIS
ROOM RIGHT NOW- THIS BILL ALSO
ALLOWS PRODUCTION STERN A
HIGHER PERCENTAGE OF CREDITS BY
MEETING WORKFORCE DIVERSITY
GOALS. THAT'S A SIGNIFICANT
PIECE OF THE BILL- THE
PRODUCTIONS WILL BE WILL. BE
REQUIRED TO CREATE THEIR OWN
DIVERSITY PLANS WHICH IS ALSO
VERY IMPORTANT BECAUSE IT'S A
SELF. MONITORING EFFORT AND
WILL COMPLY WITH STATE AND
FEDERAL LAWS BY HAVING IT BE
THAT WAY AND AGAIN I WANT TO
GIVE. A SHOUT OUT TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CARILLO FOR BEING SO
PASSIONATE ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE
OF DIVERSITY GOALS AND
INCREASING A DIVERSE DIVERSE
WORK FORCE. IN THE
ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY THAT
REFLECTS WHAT CALIFORNIA IS
TODAY. THE BILL ALSO REQUIRES
ADDITIONAL REPORTING RELATED TO
WORKFORCE DIVERSITY THROUGHOUT
THE FILM INDUSTRY AGAIN A VERY
IMPORTANT STEP FORWARD. SB ONE
FOUR FOUR IS VITALLY IMPORTANT
TO CALIFORNIA FRANKLY I
REPRESENT BURBANK AND GLENDALE
HOME TO I THINK THE BEST
DIDN'T. WITH ALL DUE RESPECT
THE BEST DISTRICT IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. AND HOME TO MANY
OF OUR LONG STANDING AND
IMPORTANT STUDIO AND TV
COMPANIES THAT HAVE BEEN PART
OF THE FABRIC OF CALIFORNIA.
FOR A HUNDRED YEARS FOR
BACKGROUND THE EXODUS OF FILM
AND TELEVISION PRODUCTIONS
OUTSIDE OF CALIFORNIA. THREATEN
ONE OF THIS HISTORIC INDUSTRIES
ON OUR STATE. AND FOR DECADES
PROVIDED GOOD STABLE MIDDLE
CLASS MOSTLY WELL REPRESENTED
UNION JOBS IN RECENT YEARS. IT
HAD BECOME OBVIOUS THAT WE
NEEDED TO ENHANCE THEM
INCENTIVES TO LOWER BACK AND
KEEP PRODUCTION IN CALIFORNIA.
AND THE FIRST STEP WAS THE
EXISTING FILM PRODUCTION TAX
CREDITS. SB ONE FOUR FOUR
BUILDS OFF ON THE RESOUNDING
SUCCESS OF THESE CREDITS WHICH
IS MOVED DOZENS OF PRODUCTIONS
BACK TO SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA FILMING
HAS INCREASED- I KNOW RECENTLY.
GOOD GIANT FILM PRODUCTION
THAT- USE NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
AS IS ECHT EXTERIOR LOCATIONS
BY EXPANDING EXISTING TAX
CREDIT AND BY INVESTING IN THE
MODERNIZATION OF THE STUDIO
INFRASTRUCTURE. AND BUILDING OF
NEW STUDIOS SB ONE FOUR FOUR
WILL NOT ONLY PUT THOUSANDS OF
HARDWORKING TRAITS PEOPLE TO
WORK WILL ALSO ENSURE THAT
ANOTHER GENERATION OF
ENTERTAINMENT WILL BE CREATED.
IN CALIFORNIA BY TRAINING THE
NEXT GENERATION OF WORKERS FOR
THIS INDUSTRY. ULTIMATELY THE
BILL ENSURES THAT CALIFORNIA
RIVER REMAINS THE GLOBAL LEADER
IN ENTERTAINMENT PRODUCTION I
ALSO WANT TO GIVE A BIG SHOUT
OUT TO THE BUILDING TRADES
WHICH HAVE BEEN. TIRELESSLY AND
PASSIONATELY. SUPPORTIVE OF
THIS EFFORT TO CREATE THESE
CONSTRUCTION JOBS AND WE'RE
HERE BECAUSE OF THOSE EFFORTS
AS WELL SO ON THE PHONE I KNOW
WE HAVE RON MILLER THE
EXECUTIVE SECRETARY OF THE LOS
ANGELES AND ORANGE COUNTY
BUILDING TRADES. COUNCIL AND IN
PERSON WE HAVE MELISSA PROTECT
THE VICE PRESIDENT SENIOR
COUNSEL THE MOTION PICTURE
ASSOCIATION OF AMERICA. AND I
BELIEVE WE ALSO HAVE SOMEBODY
FROM DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ON
THE LINE FOR TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS AS WELL SO WITH THAT
I'LL GO TO MY PRIMARY
WITNESSES. FANTASTIC MODERATOR
WE PLEASE CONNECT US WITH RON
MILLER OF THE LOS ANGELES AND
ORANGE COUNTY SPELLING TRAITS.
PLEASE GO AHEAD MR MILLER. GOOD
MORNING THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
HAVING ME CHAIR AND- COMMITTEE
MEMBERS RON MILLER EXECUTIVE
SECRETARY VALLEY ORANGE COUNTY
BUILDING TRADES HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE STATE BUILDING TRADES
COUNCIL AND ALL THE FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND MEMBERS UP AND
DOWN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
IN SUPPORT OF SB ONE FORTY FOUR
THIS BILL SEEKS TO KEEP
CALIFORNIA THE GLOBAL LEADER IN
ENTERTAINMENT PRODUCTION. SB
ONE FORTY FOUR BILLS OFF THE
RESOUNDING SUCCESS OF
CALIFORNIA'S FILM TAX CREDIT
WHICH IS MOVED DOZENS OF
PRODUCTIONS BACK TO SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA FOLLOWING A DECADE
LONG DECLINE IN HOLLYWOOD.
SINCE ITS INCEPTION THE FILM
TAX CREDIT IS GENERATED SIX
BILLION DOLLARS WITH IN
CALIFORNIA DESPITE OUR EIGHT
HUNDRED FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLAR
IN INCENTIVES FROM THE STATE.
IN TURN PRODUCTIONS ELIGIBLE
FOR CREDIT BENEFIT LOCAL
BUSINESSES AND COMMUNTIES BY
EMPLOYING RENTAL AND STORAGE
COMPANIES CATERING BUSINESSES
INCREASING PARKING REVENUE
PERMITTING REVENUE. FOR THESE
RIVAS REASONS EXPERTS HAVE
ESTIMATED THAT EVERY PRODUCTION
AMOUNTS AMOUNT MULTIPLIED BY
THREE FOR ECONOMIC GROWTH. IN
MANY WAYS SB ONE FORTY FOUR
MARES EXISTING FILM TAX CREDIT
PROGRAM BUT IT'S FORMULATED
SPECIFICALLY. FOR STUDIO
CONSTRUCTION AND RENOVATION
PROJECTS CERTIFIED BY THE
CALIFORNIA FILM COMMISSION IN
ORDER TO QUALIFY FOR THE CREDIT
ELIGIBLE PRODUCTS MUST BE BUILT
INTEREST IN STATE MEET
APPROPRIATE COST THRESHOLDS.
AND SUBJECT TO PROBATE
PREVAILING WAGE AND SKILLED AND
TRAINED WORKFORCE REQUIREMENTS.
THESE RECALL. FOR WHAT PROVIDE
A PATHWAY TO GOOD MIDDLE CLASS
CAREERS FOR THE FUTURE
WORKFORCE OF CALIFORNIA. AND
THE STATE BUILDING TRADES UP
AND DOWN THE STATE HAVE
EMBRACED THESE PROGRAMS AND
PARTICIPATE IN- WHOLEHEARTEDLY.
AND NOW THE STATE BUILDING
TRADES- MEMBERSHIP LOOKS LIKE
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE HAVE
BEEN VERY SUCCESSFUL IN WORKING
IN COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. TO PUT
PEOPLE INTO THE APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS. THEM AND BUILD THE
WORKFORCE OF TOMORROW. OVER THE
PAST YEAR NEVER HAVE MARKETS
BEEN SO GRATEFUL FOR CALIFORNIA
MADE ENTERTAINMENT THIS
STREAMED. THEM THROUGH AN
OTHERWISE LONELY TIME. ALTHOUGH
PRODUCTION WAS SHATTERED FOR A
LARGE PART OF THE YEAR THIS
YEAR DUE TO A COLBERT PEDANTIC
WE BELIEVE THAT EFFORTS LIKE SB
ONE FORTY FOUR WILL ALLOW THE
ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY IN
CALIFORNIA. TO NOT ONLY RECOVER
BUT TO GROW. BY INVESTING IN
THE FUTURE OF THE IN STATE
ENTERTAINMENT WE'RE SUPPORTING
A CRUCIAL INDUSTRY MILLIONS OF
JOBS AND ENSURING THAT
CALIFORNIA REMAINS THE GLOBAL
LEADER FOR ENTERTAINMENT
CREATION AND PRODUCTION. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH PLEASE SUPPORT
THIS BILL. THANK YOU I
UNDERSTAND THE NEXT PRIMARY
WITNESS IN SUPPORT IS IN
PERSON. MOSA PATAK THE MOTION
PICTURE ASSOCIATION OF AMERICA.
CHAIR BIRTH MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I AM MELISSA PATAK
VICE PRESIDENT SENIOR COUNSEL
FOR STATE GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS
WITH THE MOTION PICTURE
ASSOCIATION THE MPA IS THE
TRADE ASSOCIATION FOR THE
LEADING PRODUCERS AND
DISTRIBUTORS OF MOTION PICTURES
TELEVISION PROGRAMS AND
STREAMING SERIES. OUR MEMBERS
INCLUDE DISNEY NBCUNIVERSAL
NETFLIX PARAMOUNT PICTURES SONY
PICTURES AND WARNER BROTHERS
MPA SUPPORTS SB ONE FORTY FOUR.
THIS BILL HAS THREE ELEMENTS
INCENTIVIZING THE CONSTRUCTION
AND RENOVATION OF SOUNDSTAGES
ASSURING CONTINUITY OF
RECURRING TV SERIES AND
ENHANCING DIVERSITY. WE
APPRECIATE THE LEADERSHIP OF
THE BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADE UNIONS AND WORKING WITH
SENATOR PORTANTINO ON
LEGISLATION EARLIER THIS YEAR
TO INCENTIVIZE THE CONSTRUCTION
AND RENOVATION OF SOUNDSTAGES.
MPA WAS A PLEASED TO SUPPORT
THAT BILL AND WE SUPPORT
INCORPORATING IT INTO THIS BILL
ALONG WITH THE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING FOR THE RECURRING TV
SERIES. WE ALSO ACKNOWLEDGE AND
APPRECIATE THE HARD WORK OF THE
ENTERTAINMENT UNIONS INCLUDING
IATSE TEAMSTERS THE LABOR SAG
AFTRA AND THE DIRECTORS GUILD
ON BOTH THE INFRASTRUCTURE BILL
AND THE TAX CREDITS FOR
RECURRING TV SERIES. TOGETHER
THE MPA AND ENTERTAINMENT
UNIONS COALITION HAVE ADVOCATED
FOR THE CALIFORNIA FILM AND
TELEVISION PRODUCTION TAX
CREDIT PROGRAM OVER MANY YEARS.
THE RESULTS ARE SELF EVIDENT.
FROM THE CALIFORNIA FILM
COMMISSION'S MOST RECENT
DECEMBER TWENTY TWENTY PROGRESS
REPORT WE KNOW THAT THE STATE'S
INVESTMENT OF ONE POINT FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS IN TAX CREDITS
HAS YIELDED ELEVEN POINT TWO
BILLION DOLLARS IN DIRECT IN
STATE SPENDING. BETWEEN TWENTY
FIFTEEN AND TWENTY TWENTY THE
PRODUCTIONS RECEIVING TAX
CREDITS HAVE HIRED ALMOST FORTY
FOUR THOUSAND CREW MEMBERS AND
MORE THAN THIRTY FOUR THOUSAND
CAST MEMBERS. AND THIS PROGRAM
IS ATTRACTED TWENTY SIX
TELEVISION SERIES BACK TO
CALIFORNIA FROM OTHER LOCALES.
THE ADDITIONAL FUNDING PROVIDED
FOR RECURRING TV SERIES WILL
NAY IT WILL ENABLE THOSE
PROJECTS TO CONTINUE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. EMPLOYING
CALIFORNIANS AND ENGAGING
CALIFORNIA LOCAL BUSINESSES TO
SUPPLY GOODS AND SERVICES TO
THESE PRODUCTIONS. THIS IS A
LIMITED ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR
THIS FISCAL YEAR AND NEXT. THE
OTHER PART OF THIS BILL CREATES
A PROGRAM WITHIN THE EXISTING
PRODUCTION TAX CREDIT PROGRAM
TO INCENTIVIZE THE BUILDING AND
RENOVATION OF SOUNDSTAGES IN
CALIFORNIA. IN ORDER TO
CONTINUE TO GROW PRODUCTION AND
THE GOOD MIDDLE CLASS UNION
JOBS. CALIFORNIA NEEDS MORE
SOUND STAGES. THE PROVISIONS OF
SB ONE FORTY FOUR WILL
INCENTIVIZE PRIVATE INVESTMENT
IN PRODUCTION INFRASTRUCTURE.
TO CREATE THOUSANDS OF NEW JOBS
BY PROVIDING PRODUCTION
INCENTIVES TO PROJECTS THAT
WILL BE LOCATED IN THESE NEWLY
BUILT OR RENOVATED SOUNDSTAGES.
THOSE STAGES WILL BE BUILT TO
RENOVATED AND MAINTAINED BY
UNION WORKERS AMONG OTHER
REQUIREMENTS IN THE BILL.
DISINCENTIVE ENSURES LONG TERM
RETURNS FOR CALIFORNIA FOR A
RELATIVELY SHORT INVESTMENT
PERIOD. BY WAY OF ILLUSTRATION
MOST OF THE STUDIOS IN
CALIFORNIA BUILT THEIR SOUND
STAGES IN THE NINETEEN TWENTIES
AND THIRTIES. BUT THEY ARE ALL
STILL WORKING TODAY. THE LIFE
SANTA LIFESPAN OF A SOUND STAGE
IS MORE THAN A CENTURY. FOR THE
APPROXIMATELY THREE YEARS THIS
BILL CREATES INCENTIVES FOR THE
BUILDING AND RENOVATION OF
SOUNDSTAGES. CALIFORNIA WILL
GET. MORE THAN NINETY YEARS OF
PRODUCTION WORK AND THE
ACCOMPANYING JOBS FROM THEM IN
THE FUTURE. FINALLY THIS BILL
ADDS SOME NEW PROVISIONS ON
DIVERSITY FOR THE GENERAL
PRODUCTION TAX CREDIT PROGRAM
THIS BILL IMPROVES THE
COLLECTION OF DATA ABOUT THE
WORK FORCE FOR EACH PRODUCTION.
THE BILL REQUIRES WORKFORCE
INFORMATION TO BE PROVIDED TO
THE CALIFORNIA FILM COMMISSION
PRIOR TO THE ISSUANCE OF A TAX
CREDIT CERTIFICATE AT THE END
OF THE PRODUCTION WHEN. THERE'S
A LOT OF INFORMATION ABOUT WHO
WAS ACTUALLY HIRED. AND FOR
THOSE PRODUCTIONS THAT WILL BE
LOCATED ON THE NEW OR RENOVATED
INFRASTRUCTURE THEY WILL BE
ELIGIBLE FOR AN ADDITIONAL
AMOUNT OF TAX CREDIT. IN ORDER
TO GET A TOP LEFT PRODUCTIONS
WILL HAVE TO ACHIEVE A WORK
FORCE PLAN APPROVED BY THE
CALIFORNIA FILM COMMISSION THAT
REPRESENTS CALIFORNIA. THANK
YOU FOR HEARING THIS BILL AT
THIS TIME. WE ARE CHEN AYE VOTE
ON SB ONE FORTY FOUR I'M HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS AND
AGAIN THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANYONE
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
VIA REMOTE STATION AT THIS TIME.
I BELIEVE WE HAVE FALLEN. THERE
WE GO. WE CAN'T HEAR YOU. MADAM
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS MIKE WEST
ON BEHALF OF THE INTERNATIONAL
UNION OF PAINTERS AND ALLIED
TRADES STANDING IN SOLIDARITY
WITH THE STATE BUILDING TRADES
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
OPERATOR WE OPEN THE MAINLINE
FOR THIS WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU TO EXPRESS SUPPORT
FOR TODAY- PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO NET TEE
OPERATORS GOING TO GO AHEAD
GIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER I FIND IN
A PLACE YOU BACK IN THE QUEUE
AGAIN DO OUR SHOW SUPPORT AT
THIS TIME PLEASE PRESS. ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AND WE WILL
NINE TWENTY EIGHT. PLEASE GO
AHEAD TWENTY. MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MATH PROBLEM BE AFTER
THE TEAMSTERS AND SAG AFTER IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. YOU CAN.
NINE THIRTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THIRTY FOUR YOU MUTED.
THAT GOOD MORNING ERIN LEHANE
ON BEHALF OF A HALF MILLION
MEMBERS OF THE STATE BUILDING
AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
CALIFORNIA MANY OF WHOM WORK ON
WHAT SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
INSTRUCT THE PORT OF ITSELF
THANK YOU. WE WILL GO TO LINE
FORTY TWO YOU ARE OPEN. FORTY
TO PLEASE- YOU. ONE MORE TRY A
LINE FORTY TWO WOULD YOU LIKE
TO TESTIFY. MOVING ALONG THE
LINE THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI THIS IS DAVID BEANIE WITH
THE SANTA CLARA AND SAN BENITO
COUNTIES BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL AND
WE STAND IN SUPPORT OF THE OF
SB ONE FORTY FOUR WITH THE
STATE BUILDING TRADES THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. FIND TWENTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES HI ED
DUFFY ON BEHALF OF TEAMSTERS
LOCAL THREE NINETY NINE IN
ORDER TO PORT. THANK YOU. ONE
TWENTY SEVEN YOU ARE OPEN. YES
TOM DAVIS PRESIDENT OF THE
ENTERTAINMENT UNION COALITION
CALIFORNIA IDEAS HE- CALLED-
UNIONS AS WELL AS ON THE IDEAS
SEE- THANK YOU FOR YOUR IN THE
BILL AND WE STAND IN FULL
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ONE THIRTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
NANCY JOHNSON WOULD NIELSEN
MARK MARK CALLING IN ON BEHALF
OF THE DIRECTORS GUILD OF
AMERICA IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
ONE FORTY FOUR THANK YOU. WHY
TWENTY FIVE YOUR UP. GOOD
MORNING ANTONIO SANCHEZ WITH
IBEW LOCAL ELEVEN IN LOS
ANGELES I'LL BE OUT OF OUR
TWELVE THOUSAND MEMBERS AND TWO
THOUSAND CANISTERS WEREN'T FULL
SUPPORT THANK YOU. ONE FOURTEEN
YOU ARE OPEN. CAN YOU HEAR AN
AWARD. YES CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEP MICHAEL
LABRECQUE REPRESENTING WARNER
BROTHERS ENTERTAINMENT EACH BE
A WARM MEDIA WERE IN FULL
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THANK YOU
MIKE EXCUSE ME OUTLINED TWENTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
MARK PLAN BUSINESS MANAGER IBEW
LOCAL FORTY REPRESENTING THE
MOTION PICTURE LECTURES IN
INDUSTRY FOR NINETY SEVEN YEARS
IN STRONG SUPPORT A BILL SB ONE
FORTY FOUR THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ONE THIRTY THREE YOU ARE OPEN.
I AM GILBERT PREETO FROM LOCAL
FOR THIRTY ONE JOINT COUNCIL
SEVEN I AM JOINING THE STATE
BUILDING TRADES IN THEIR
SUPPORT OF SB ONE FORTY FOUR.
THANK YOU. THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. A GOOD MORNING JOHN
ROSS KP PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON
BEHALF OF NBC UNIVERSAL IN
SUPPORT THE- TWENTY TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS THIS IS CASEY
O'CONNOR LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR
FOR STATE TREASURER FIONA MOMMA
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
ONE FORTY FOUR AND WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR AND SPONSORS
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD.
THANK YOU. X. WILL GO TO LINE
THIRTY SEVEN YOU ARE OPEN.
KATHY COMMITTEE ON BEHALF OF
THE HUNDRED AND SIXTY THREE
THOUSAND MEMBERS OF THE
ENTERTAINMENT UNION COALITION
AND ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA OUT
TO COUNSEL IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THIRTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIRTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MY NAME IS NEXT ABOUT A I'M
FROM IBEW LOCAL SIX EIGHTY FOUR
IN MODESTO CALIFORNIA AND WE'RE
JOINING THE STATE BUILDING
TRADES AND THEIR SUPPORT OF S.
B. ONE FORTY FOUR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ONE THIRTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME
IS RICK SMILES ON BEHALF OF
JUMPED OUT OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT COUNCIL OF
LABORERS WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB ONE FORTY FOUR
AND SEVEN. REALLY GREAT. LINE
FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MIKE
PRATT WOULD TEAMSTER LOCAL FOR
THIRTY ONE FRESNO FOR A JOINT
COUNCIL SEVEN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA- GOINGTO BILLION
TRADE STRONG SUPPORT OF SB ONE
FORTY FOUR THANK YOU. X. WE
WILL LINE. TWENTY SIX YOUR OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS MARK
BOOK FROM INTERNATIONAL
BROTHERHOOD OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS OF ALAMEDA COUNTY
CALAVERAS AND SAN JOAQUIN WITH
OVER TWO THOUSAND MEMBERS WE
STAND WITH THE BUILDINGS TRADE
HAS GONE TO COURT AT THREE. ONE
FOUR FOUR THANK YOU. NEXT IS
LINE NINETEEN EUROPE. MY NAME
IS JOHN WITH UNITED ASSOCIATION
OF PLUMBERS AND PIPEFITTERS
LOCAL FOUR FOUR SEVEN IN THE
SACRAMENTO REGION AND WE'RE
WITH THE STATE BUILDING TRADES
IN SUPPORT OF SB ONE FORTY
FOUR. THANK YOU. ONE TWENTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS
IS DOUG PHONY WITH I. EIGHTY AT
THE LOCAL EIGHT EIGHT OR IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THIS TIME
I'LL GIVE A REMINDER I TO GO
AHEAD SHOW SUPPORT. PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT
THIS TIME ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO.
AND WE'LL GO TO LINE THIRTY
NINE. GOOD MORNING RONNIE
VALENTINE I ATSC LOCAL NUMBER
THIRTY THREE REPRESENTING LOS
ANGELES FOR ONE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY FIVE YEARS THIS YEAR WE
ARE HAPPY TO SAY WE ARE IN FULL
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL SB ONE
FORTY FOUR THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NEXT IN LINE TWENTY FOUR YOU
ARE OPEN. HI GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS FRANCISCO ARRIVE ON
WITH THE INTERNATIONAL
BROTHERHOOD OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS LOCAL ELEVEN- WE ARE A
FULL SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AND
SOLIDARITY WITH THE STATE BUT
ENTERED. INTO THINKING. THANK
SIXTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
GOOD MORNING NO MATTER GERMINAL
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THIS IS JOHN
MORALIS WITH TEAMSTERS LOCAL
EIGHTY SEVEN PRESS OFFICER. AND
WE ARE IN FULL SUPPORT OF S. B.
ONE FOUR FOUR THANK YOU. AND
NEXT WE WILL GO TO ONE MOMENT.
LINE FORTY TO YOUR OFFICE.
HELLO GOOD MORNING TERM NUMBERS
WITH THE JENNIFER MALLEY WITH A
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
STANDING IN SUPPORT WITH- THE
ENTERTAINING YOU IN UNION
COALITION I HAPPY COUNCIL IN
THE BUILDING TRADE ACCORD SB.
ONE FORTY FOUR. AND AS A FINAL
REMINDER OF THE PHONE LINES TO
SHOW SUPPORT FOR SB ONE FORTY
FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND WE
WILL GO TO LINE FORTY ONE YOU
ARE OPEN. YES IS MARTIN
RODRIGUEZ I WORK WITH LOCAL FOR
THIRTY THREE WE STAND IN
SOLIDARITY WITH THE BUILDING
TRADES. IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU. NINE THIRTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO. THIS IS KATHY
COMMITTEE ON BEHALF OF THE
INTERNATIONAL CINEMATOGRAPHERS
GUILD LOCAL SIX HUNDRED
ATHLETES IN STRONG SUPPORT.
NINE FORTY FOUR YOU ARE OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS CARLOS
CODA CALLING IN REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA EIGHTY IF YOU
COUNSEL AND IDEAS THE LOCAL ONE
TWENTY TWO SAN DIEGO CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF S. B. ONE
THIRTY FOUR AND I THANK YOU ALL
FOR YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
AND I'M SURE WE HAVE EXHAUSTED
THE QUEUE AT THIS POINT. CURRY
I SEE WE HAVE WE HAVE PEOPLE
HERE TO TESTIFY IN PERSON.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF MIKE
MADIGAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
ELECTRICAL WORKERS THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PIPE TRADES
COUNCIL. AND THE WESTERN STATES
COUNCIL OF SHEET METAL WORKERS
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS CHRISTMAS CEILIDH
ON BEHALF OF THE HOLLYWOOD
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE IN SUPPORT
OF CENTER PORTANTINO'S BILL
THANK YOU. MODERATOR IS THERE
ANYONE WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. ON THE PHONE.
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB ONE
FOUR FOUR PLEASE PRESS THE ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS TIME
ONE FELL BY ZERO TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB. ONE FORTY
FOUR. NO PARTICIPANTS ARE
QUEUING UP GREAT IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION IN THE VIDEO REMOTE
CENTER. SEEING NINE ANY
OPPOSITION HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM. NINE COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
DR CORK. SO IF THERE'S ANY YEAR
WE HAVE SEVENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS AVAILABLE THIS IS A-
WHAT BUT- WHAT I'M CONCERNED
ABOUT THE BILL IS THAT IT CAN
TAKE MONEY AWAY FROM OTHER
PURPOSES- AND GIVE IT SO YOU'RE
GIVING THIS THE HIGHEST
PRIORITY WHY IS THAT. WELL I
THINK THERE'S A SIMPLE QUESTION.
YOU KNOW WHEN YOU LOOK AT AN
INCENTIVE IT'S TO CREATE MORE
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AND MORE
JOBS IT CREATES MORE OF AN
ECONOMIC BENEFIT. FROM PRIMING
THE PUMP THEN THE ACTUAL
DOLLARS IN A STATIC. THE COUNTY
SYSTEM THAT'S ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES WE HAVE IN THE
LEGISLATURE IS WE BUDGET IN A
STATIC EXPENDITURE MODEL NOT AN
INVESTMENT MODEL THIS MONEY
WILL LEAD TO BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS OF ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
WHICH WILL CREATE MORE TAX
REVENUE WHICH WILL CREATE. MORE
JOBS WILL CREATE MORE. WAGES
AND BENEFITS THE STATE GREATER
THAN THE INVESTMENT RIGHT NOW
THAT I UNDERSTAND WHEN I WHEN I
DON'T KNOW IS WHY YOU'RE TAKING
MONEY FROM THE OTHER THREE
HUNDRED THIRTY MILLION. THAT
WAS DESIGNATED FOR OTHER
PURPOSES. IF THERE ISN'T ENOUGH
IF THERE'S A GREATER TAX CREDIT
FOR THE SEVENTY FIVE MILLION
WHAT CHANGES. IF YOU IF YOU.
OVER IF YOU SPEND ALL THE
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION ON THIS
TAX CREDIT. THEN YOU TAKE AWAY
AND THEN AND THERE'S STILL MORE
PEOPLE WHO WANT TO BUILD. THEN
YOU'RE TAKING AWAY MONEY FROM
OTHER FUNDS WITHIN THE THREE
HUNDRED THIRTY MILLION. NO THE
PRODUCTIONS GET IN LINE AND
COMPETE WITH THE PROTECTIONS
THAT ARE ALREADY IN THE QUEUE
FOR THAT THREE HUNDRED THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS AND THEIR
SAFEGUARDS. WITHIN THE BILL TO
PROTECT IT FROM BEING OVER
PRESCRIBED WHICH IS THE
SITUATION THAT WE'RE IN TODAY-
IT THERE SEEMS TO BE SOMEBODY
WILL WIN THE- HE WATCHED ANSWER
THE QUESTIONS. MADAM CHAIR
BECAUSE THE TOPIC WOULD YOU
LIKE TO ANSWER. THANK YOU
MELISSA TACK WITH THE MOTION
PICTURE ASSOCIATION SO I THINK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF QUICK YOU'RE
REFERRING TO THE SECTION IN THE
BILL THAT SAYS- IF THERE'S A
SHORTFALL IN THE FUTURE. YOU
TAKE FROM RELOCATING TV OR FROM
RECURRING TV AND FROM FEATURE
FILM SO ON. THIS SHORTFALL IS
THERE IS A- WELL A SHORTFALL IS
NEVER A GOOD SITUATION THIS IS
A RESULT OF GOOD NEWS ANOTHER'S
WE'VE ATTRACTED SO MANY
RELOCATING TV SERIES. ON THERE
IS A SPECIAL BUCKET AS YOU KNOW
IN THE PROGRAM FOR RELOCATING
TV SERIES BUT ONCE THAT
RELOCATING TV SERIES IS HERE
FOR A YEAR AND THEN WITH LUCK
IT GETS REDUCED BECAUSE IT'S A
SUCCESSFUL TV SERIES. IT THEN
SHARES FROM THE POT OF
RECURRING TV AND WE'VE NOW
ATTRACTED SO MANY RELOCATING TV
SERIES. THAT THERE AREN'T.
A TV
SERIES AND NOW THIS ANTI IN
ALICE'S. I'M SORRY IT ALSO
COMES FROM FEATURE FILM YES
THOUGH IT WE HOPE THAT THAT
DOES NOT COME TO PASS FEATURE
FILMS ARE REALLY IMPORTANT
PRIORITY IN THE FILM TAX CREDIT
PROGRAM I AND WE IT WOULD BE
YOU KNOW THESE ARE LAST RESORTS
FOR A SITUATION THAT WE REALLY
DON'T BELIEVE WILL COME TO PASS
BUT IT'S A THEIR ****
PRECAUTIONARY. LANGUAGE JUST IN
CASE THANK YOU IF I COULD ADD
MANAGER YOU ALSO NEED TO CREATE
THE STABILITY OF THOSE
PRODUCTIONS TO KNOW THAT IF
THEY ARE ON GOING THAT THEY
HAVE OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUETO
RECEIVE- WITH THE PROTECTION OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND-
FOR PUT IN THE BILL SO THAT'S
ALSO PART OF IT IS THAT
STABILITY FACTOR. THANK YOU
MISS PEACH IN ARMS WILL JUST GO
DOWN THIS. PATH THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. AND GOOD MORNING SENATOR
GOOD TO SEE YOU ARE LET ME LET
ME START BY SAYING THAT I AM
HAPPY TO SUPPORT SB ONE FORTY
FOUR TODAY. I THINK YOU AND AT
YOUR SUPPORTERS HAVE MADE A
REALLY COMPELLING CASE. FOR THE
ADVOCACY AS THESE TAX CREDITS I
THINK YOU YOU SPOKE TO THE
RESOUNDING SUCCESS AT THESE TAX
CREDITS IN. CREATING GOOD JOBS
IN STIMULATING ECONOMIC GROWTH
AND DEVELOPMENT. I'M BUT I ALSO
DO YOU WANT TO ADD THAT AS I
LISTEN TO THIS CONVERSATION I
KIND OF TAKE A STEP BACK. I'M
IT DOES LEAVE ME A LITTLE BIT
SCRATCHING MY HEAD ABOUT OUR-
TAX POLICY MORE BROADLY. ON
BECAUSE WHEN WE TALK ABOUT TAX
CREDITS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE'VE GOT SOME
REALLY REALLY UNIMPORTANT.
REALLY IMPORTANT UNFINISHED
BUSINESS FROM. LAST BUDGET YEAR
SO IS EVERYONE WILL RECALL I
IN. THE LAST BUDGET CYCLE WE%
THOUGHT WE WERE FACING A
HISTORIC BUDGET DEFICIT A
THIRTY FOUR BILLION DOLLAR
BUDGET DEFICIT AMONGST OTHER
THINGS- WE ENACTED AB EIGHTY
FIVE. WHICH SUSPENDED AT THE
NET OPERATING LOSS UTILIZATION
AND ALSO IMPOSED A CAP OF FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS ON THE AMOUNT
AT BUSINESS INCENTIVE TAX
CREDITS THAT COMPANIES CAN
UTILIZE- FOR THE NEXT THREE
YEARS. THAT INCLUDES THE- JOB
TAX CREDIT THE MOTION PICTURE
PRODUCTION CREDIT THE
CALIFORNIA COMPETES CREDIT. AND
THE RESEARCH AND DEVELOPMENT.
TAX CREDIT. ON SO IN MY VIEW.
AT NOW THAT WE FIND OURSELVES
IN. THE A REMARKABLY AND
BLESSEDLY A MUCH DIFFERENT A
MUCH BETTER POSITION WE'VE GOT
A SEVENTY FIVE BILLION DOLLAR.
BUDGET SURPLUS. I THINK IN IN
IN ADDITION TO AN ACTING SB ONE
FORTY FOUR. I WOULD LIKE TO SEE
US RESTORE. TAX CREDITS MORE
BROADLY AND LIFT THAT CAP MORE
BROADLY I THINK IT'S ACTUALLY.
FIVE THURMOND UNCONSCIONABLE
THAT WE ARE ACCRUING NOT
LIABILITY RIGHT NOW FOR THE OUT
YEARS PARTICULARLY IN LIGHT AND
AS I SAID WHAT I FELT WAS A
VERY COMPELLING CASE YOU MADE
FOR JUST HOW IMPORTANT. THESE
TAX CREDITS ARE IN SO MANY
INDUSTRIES IN CREATING GOOD
JOBS AND STIMULATING ECONOMIC
GROWTH SO ON LIKE I SAID HAPPY
TO SUPPORT SB ONE FORTY FOUR
TODAY AND LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH. THE
FILM INDUSTRY WITH ODD LIFE
SCIENCES INDUSTRY WITH TECH
INDUSTRY AND OTHERS TO ENSURE
THAT WE ARE GLAD MAKING SMART
INVESTMENTS TO STIMULATE
GROWTH. IN REGIONS ACROSS THE
STATE AND INDUSTRIES ALL ACROSS
THE STATE. DEPT THANK YOU
SENATOR THANK YOU. I GUESS WE
ALL GET TO TALK- CENTER THANK
YOU FOR- TAKE A TAKEN THIS ON-
AS SOMEONE WHO HAS HAD FAMILY
MEMBERS- IN THE INDUSTRY SINCE
THE FORTIES- I CAN TELL YOU HOW
IMPORTANT THE FILM INDUSTRY HAS
BEEN. AND A LOT OF PEOPLE THINK
IT'S JUST AFFECTS THE THEY SEE
THE ACTORS AND THE ACTRESSES
BUT THEY DON'T REALIZE THE
PEOPLE THAT WORK BEHIND THE
SCENES- TO MAKE ALL THAT
HAPPEN- IT WORKING IN THE CITY
OF INGLEWOOD WE HAD A LOT OF
FILMING GOING ON IN THE
EIGHTIES AND NINETIES. AND THEN
ALL THE SUDDEN IT DRIED UP. AND
NONE OF THESE FOLKS ONE OF MY
GOOD COLLEAGUES HERE- WERE. IN
IN THE ASSEMBLY OR THE OR IN
THE LEGISLATURE AT THE TIME-
BUT WE ENACTED SOME POLICIES-
THAT THE FILM INDUSTRY SAID. IF
YOU GUYS KEEP DOING THIS WE'RE
WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE IN
CALIFORNIA. IN IN THE FILM
INDUSTRY WAS BORN IN CALIFORNIA
BELONGS IN CALIFORNIA. AND SO.
YOU KNOW IT'S KIND OF A LESSON
LEARNED. BECAUSE HERE WE ARE. A
DECADE AND A HALF LATER- LURING
THEM BACK. WITH TAX INCENTIVES
WHICH IS YOU KNOW IF THAT'S
WHAT WE GOTTA DO THEN THAT'S
WHAT WE GOTTA DO. BUT WE SHOULD
NOT CHASE THEM OUT IN THE FIRST
PLACE AND WE NEED TO RE LOOK AT
SOME OF WE NEED TO LEARN FROM
HISTORY. ABOUT SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT WE DO TO IMPACT WE
CAN'T SOMEONE KNOWS IT AN
INDUSTRY LIKE THAT. BECAUSE
THOSE THOUSANDS OF JOBS I HAD
YEAH I HAD COUSINS THEY HAD TO
RETIRE EARLY. AND NEVER TRADE
YEAH THEY WERE UNION WORKERS- I
HAD OTHER FRIENDS THAT HAD TO
TRAIN PEOPLE FROM OTHER STATES
THAT WERE TAKEN THEIR JOBS- IT
WAS PAINFUL FOR A LOT OF PEOPLE.
AND HOPEFULLY WE CAN LEARN OUR
LESSONS FROM WHAT HAPPENED- WE
CAN LOOK BACK AND SEE WHAT IT
WAS THAT. WAS WHAT'S HAPPENING
AT THE TIME THAT MADE IT SO.
UNTENABLE FOR SUCH AN IMPORTANT
INDUSTRY TO BE IN CALIFORNIA.
AND AND HOPEFULLY WE CAN NEVER
REPEAT THAT AGAIN. BECAUSE
THOSE TYPE OF INDUSTRIES AND
THAT KIND OF ECONOMIC VITALITY.
IS SO TERRIBLY IMPORTANT. TO
OUR STATE. AND TO ALL OF THE
ALL OF THE PEOPLE THAT LIVE
HERE- A LOT OF OUR PROBLEMS ARE
SOLVED WHEN THEY'RE WORKING IN
THE WORKING THESE KIND OF JOBS.
SO ANYWAY I APPLAUD THAT WE'RE
WE'RE FINALLY LURING THEM BACK
AND I HOPE THAT CONTINUES THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
SENATOR SO GOOD TO SEE YOU- AND
REALLY REALLY GLAD THAT WE WERE
ABLE TO PARTNER IN CREATING-
THIS BILL THAT REALLY CATERS TO
A VARIETY OF DIFFERENT. TYPE OF
WORKERS BOTH BELOW THE LINE
ABOVE THE LINE I WANT TO- JUST
SHARES A LITTLE BIT OF SOME TO-
STATISTICS RELATED TO EQUITY
AND DIVERSITY WHICH AS YOU
MENTIONED IS SOMETHING THAT WE
WORKED REALLY REALLY HARD ON.
AND BUDGETS UP FOR AND I WANT
TO TAKE A MOMENT TO JUST THINK.
GENEVIEVE MORE- WHAT IS WITH
THE COMMITTEE AND BUDGET FOR
ALL OF HER WORK IN RESEARCH AND
DEDICATION. TO THE ISSUE OF
EQUITY AND DIVERSITY
OFTENTIMES. YOU KNOW WE SPEAK
ABOUT BEING THE ONLY WOMEN IN
THE ROOM SOMETIMES THE ONLY
WOMEN OF COLOR IN THE ROOM
SOMETIMES OFTEN THE ONLY BROWN
WOMAN IN THE ROOM. AND THE
IMPORTANCE OF WHAT THAT IS THIS
YEAR WE ALSO LAUNCHED THE
INITIATIVE FOR UNSEEN LATINOS
AND I WANT TO SHARE JUST A
LITTLE BIT OF WHAT WE DISCUSSED
AND- THE NC LEVINE AS
HOLLYWOOD- HEARING THAT WE HAD
IN TWENTY NINETEEN. THE USC
ANNENBERG INCLUSION INITIATIVE-
PUBLISHED A REPORT THAT'S VERY
SIMILAR TO THE UCLA REPORT THAT
WAS PUBLISHED EARLIER THIS
YEAR. THEY LOOKED AT TWELVE
HUNDRED TOP GROSSING FILMS FROM
200-072-2000 EIGHTEEN AND THEN
THOSE FINDINGS OF THE TOP ONE
HUNDRED GROSSING DOMESTIC
FEATURES FOR THE PAST TWELVE
YEARS. LET ME KNOW CHARACTER
MAKE UP ONLY FOUR POINT 5% OF
ALL SPEAKING ROLES AND NAMED
CHARACTERS. OUT IN THE TOP ONE
HUNDRED FILMS FROM TWENTY
EIGHTEEN FORTY SEVEN FILMS.
WERE COMPLETELY MISSING LATINO
CHARACTER SEVENTY FILMS WERE
MISSING LATINAS NINETY FIVE DID
NOT FEATURE LATINO CHARACTERS
WITH A DISABILITY NINETY EIGHT
WERE MISSING AT THE NOTES FROM
THE LGBTQ COMMUNITY. ONLY 4% OF
DIRECTORS AND 3% OF PRODUCERS
IN THESE MOVIES WERE LATINO
ONLY ONE AT THE NOT DIRECTOR
WORKED ACROSS THE TWELVE
HUNDRED FILMS EXAMINED. 47% OF
THE TWELVE HUNDRED MOVIES IN
THE REPORT. SAMPLED COMPLETELY
ERASED LATINO SPEAKING ROLES.
THIS IS SERIOUS FOR THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA LATINOS REPRESENT.
THE LARGEST- POLLUTION ACROSS
THE IN THE- AS GROWING A THE-
WHO TELLS OUR STORIES HOW THE
STORIES ARE TOLD IN WHO WRITES
THEM. IS INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT-
AND I HAVE A- A SLIGHT- JUST
DISAGREEMENT AND YOU SAYING
THAT YOU HAVE THE BEST
DISTRICTS THAT I HAVE THE BEST
DISTRICT. BUT WE SHARED THIS
BUSINESS AND COMMON YOU HAVE
THE PRODUCTION SOUNDSTAGES IN
BURBANK AND GLENDALE AND
SURROUNDING COMMUNITIES. I HAVE
THE CREATIVES I HAVE THE
WRITERS PRODUCERS DIRECTORS
ACTORS. AND ALL THE FOLKS IN
THE APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS ON
THE BELOW THE LINE. AND I THINK
WHAT WE'RE CREATING AT THIS
MOMENT IS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR A
REAL SHIFT. IN WHICH PUBLIC
DOLLARS ARE USED TO ENSURE.
THAT BOTH BELOW THE LINE AND
ABOVE THE LINE WORKERS ARE
REFLECTIVE OF THE STATE. I WANT
TO APPLAUD. THE BUILDING TRADES
SPECIALLY MISTER. RON MILLER
WHO TESTIFIED OVER THE PHONE
AND- CONGRATULATE HIM ON HIS
STEP BACK AT STEADFAST
COMMITMENT TO LABOR IN HIS
RETIREMENT. IN AUGUST BUT THE
TRADES HAVE DONE AN INCREDIBLE
JOB. IN CREATING THE PLATFORM
IN WHICH THEY ARE ABLE TO- HAVE
DATA RELATED TO GENDER TO RACE
ETHNICITY FOR THEIR WORK FORCE.
WHICH HAS ENABLED THEM TO
ACTUALLY BE ABLE TO TALK ABOUT.
ALL THE COMMUNITIES AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES THAT
THEY SERVE. WE GET TO SHIFT
THAT NOW IN DIFFERENT ASPECTS
OF LABOR TO ENSURE THAT.
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS EXPAND.
TO DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
AND ONE OF THE MOST IMPORTANT
PIECES. IS ACTUALLY ENSURING
THAT THE FILM TAX COMMISSION
BEGINS TO COLLECT THE DATA. IN
HEARINGS THAT I HAD AND SO FOR.
WE WERE OFTEN TOLD THAT THE
FILM COMMISSION DOES NOT HAVE
THE AUTHORITY TO CREATE DATA.
TO COLLECT THE DATA WE'RE
SHIFTING THAT TO ENSURE THAT.
ANY PRODUCTION MOVING FORWARD
IN THE SOUND STAGES THAT ARE
BEING NEWLY CREATED. THE
PRODUCTION COMPANIES HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CREATE A
WORKFORCE PLAN THAT IS DIVERSE
THAT IS EQUITABLE. THAT BEGINS
TO OPEN UP AVENUES IN WHICH-
REALLY THE WORK FORCE BOTH
BELOW AND ABOVE THE LINE LOOKS
LIKE THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
AND I THINK THAT'S INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT- NOT JUST TALKING
ABOUT HOW. HOW WE GET TO DO
THAT. AND CHANGING HAS TAX LIKE
OSCARS SO WHITE. BUT HOW WE
ACTUALLY CREATE A PATHWAY. IN
WHICH THAT ACTUALLY GETS TO
HAPPEN AND I THINK THAT'S
EXCITING IT'S INNOVATIVE IT'S
NEW. AND WE HAVE AN INCREDIBLE
OPPORTUNITY TO DO JUST THAT AND
I WANT TO APPLAUD YOU FOR YOUR
WORK. YOUR COMMITMENT TO YOUR
PARTNERSHIP AND ENSURING THAT
WE ARE MOVING. AND WE ARE USING
OUR STATE DOLLARS IN AN
EQUITABLE FASHION. THAT
ULTIMATELY AT THE END OF THE
DAY HOPEFULLY RESULTS IN SOME
GREAT CINEMA THANK YOU. RIGHT
AND THAT MADAM CHAIR FIVE MAY-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THE FOCUS ON
BOTH THE ABOVE THE LINE AND
BELOW THE LINE- IS REALLY
CENTRAL AND YOU WERE YOU WERE
PASSIONATE AND THAT. AND IT'S
NOT JUST THE GRIPS AND
ELECTRICIANS IT'S THE ACTORS
AND ACTRESSES AS WELL- TO MAKE
SURE THAT. THE PARTS REFLECT
THE DIVERSE REFLECT CALIFORNIA.
AND THAT WOULD NOT BE IN THIS
PROPOSAL WITHOUT YOUR EFFORTS
SO I DEFINITELY WANT TO. SEND
SEND A PROFS FACT BECAUSE IT
REALLY WAS BOTH ON THE ECONOMIC
SIDE. AND ON THE HUMAN SIDE
THIS THIS. COLLABORATION
ADDRESSES BOTH OF THOSE SO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PASSION ON
THAT. THANK. I SENATOR- I JUST
WANNA THANK YOU FOR INTRODUCING
THIS MEASURE- AND I ESPECIALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR CONSIDERATION
AND INCLUSION OF. EQUITY AND- I
ECHO MY COLLEAGUES' COMMENTS AT
THANK YOU. TAKE A MANAGER THANK
YOU SENATOR FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
ON THIS I KNOW THIS IS PERSONAL
TO YOU. ALSO FOR THE BILL TODAY
I WAS THE- A CO AUTHOR OF A-
THE TWENTY FOURTEEN ITERATION I
BELIEVE I WAS AS WELL THE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN SO AS A
STANDALONE AYE AYE SUPPORT-
THIS POLICY I THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING IT. BUT I ALSO WANT TO
THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM ORANGE
COUNTY WAS PETRIE-NORRIS A-
WHO. SHARED HER ADVOCACY- AND I
SHE IT'S AN ADVOCACY THAT I
SHARE ABOUT THE RESTORATION OF
THE LIFE SCIENCES. REDDIT SORT
OF LOOKING AT ALL OF THIS IN
TOTALITY WHEN IT COMES TO TAX
TAX CREDIT POLICY AND JOB
CREATION AND- ECONOMIC DRIVER
SO. I'M DEFINITELY READING THIS
AS AN EXPANSION OF THIS CREDIT
AND WE'VE HAD SOME DIFFICULTY
UP. NOT NOT ONLY- EXPANDING
MERELY RESTORING THE PRE
EXISTING. LIFE SCIENCES- RD
CREDIT THE PRE PANDEMIC. OPRY
SURPLUS- A DECISION THAT WAS
MADE- FROM FOR FISCAL REASONS
ON THAT LIFE SCIENCES CREDIT- I
SHOULD TELL YOU ABOUT THAT LIFE
SCIENCES PIECES PERSONAL TO ME
A SIMILAR STORY I GREW UP IN
THE BIRTHPLACE OF BIOTECHNOLOGY
CELL. ONE OF THE DRAWS HERE OF
THIS POLICY IS THIS IS A HOME
GROWN INDUSTRY- FILAMENT
PRODUCTION IS SOMETHING WE'RE
PROUD OF IN CALIFORNIA. I HAVE
MY DISTRICT I REPRESENT OVER
TWO HUNDRED LIFE SCIENCES
COMPANY SEEMS TO GROW EVERY DAY
IT IS A REAL ECONOMIC DRIVER-
IN CALIFORNIA SO- I'M JUST
HOPING THAT WE COULD LOOK AT
SORT OF ALL OF THIS IN ITS
TOTALITY WE NEED TO LOOK AT THE
EFFICACY OF ALL OF THESE- TAX
CREDITS. WITH A LOOK TO
GEOGRAPHIC BALANCE- BUT ALSO A
REAL DEEP LOOK AT WHAT ARE THE
ECONOMIC DRIVERS OF RECOVERY.
IN CALIFORNIA'S SUSTAINABLE
ECONOMIC RECOVERY SO I PLEASED
TO SUPPORT THIS I KNOW THERE'S
LOTS OF UNION SUPPORT- WHEN WE-
SEE THESE CAMPUSES GO UP IN MY
DISTRICT THEY ARE P. LA. THEY
ARE STATE BUILDING TRADES UP
PARTNERSHIPS- SO MY HOPE IS
THAT. WE CAN BRING SOME
COHERENCE TO- TAX CREDIT POLICY
CALIFORNIA THAT HELPS GET US-
BACK TO WHERE WE NEED TO BE-
TERMS OF ECONOMIC COMPETITIVE
DESPITE ALL CERTAINLY SUPPORT
THIS TODAY CENTER THANK YOU
FOR. YOUR LEADERSHIP AND LOOK
FOR TO UP SOME. FURTHER
CONVERSATIONS THANK YOU. THANK
BIG DIFFERENCE SKIPPED ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. ON THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR NUNES GIVE ME BY NO PRESS
TO SPEAK TODAY- I. HAD NOT WANT
TO BE LEFT OUT AND SENT I WILL
BE SHOWING MY SUPPORT THROUGH
MY VOTE. HOWEVER I DO ALSO WANT
TO- EXPRESSED THAT- YOUR
PASSION FOR THIS AND- TALKING
ABOUT TAX CREDIT BEING AN
INCENTIVE- IS THE SAME VALUES
THAT WE FIND IN OTHER TAX
CREDITS AS WELL. THAT HAVE BEEN
SUSPENDED AND- SURE MY COMMENTS
WITH MY COLLEAGUES. THREE OF US.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR- I'D LIKE
TO THANK YOU SENATOR FOR
WORKING ON THIS CRITICAL ISSUE
I KNOW HOW PASSIONATE YOU ARE
ABOUT THIS REPRESENT A LOT OF
STUDIOS AND IN YOUR DISTRICT
AND- AS YOUR NEIGHBOR- AND-
SOME OVERLAP A LOT OF WORKERS
LIVE IN MY DISTRICT ESPECIALLY-
BELOW THE LINE- SO I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR THIS WORK- I ALSO
APPRECIATE THE EFFORTS THAT
THIS BILL- IS MAKING AN
ENSURING THAT DIVERSITY- WITHIN
THIS INDUSTRY- IS INCLUDED IN
THIS SPELL I'M LIKE MY
COLLEAGUE FROM LOS ANGELES
MENTIONED. I WANT TO ALSO THANK
HER FOR HER WORK ON THIS TO
ENSURING THAT THIS WAS PART OF
THIS MEASURE IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT TO ME THAT THIS
INDUSTRY REFLECTS CALIFORNIA
AND THE AREAS THAT- IS THAT IT
TAKES PLACE IN WHICH IS A LOT
OF OUR DISTRICTS- YOU KNOW MY
DISTRICT IS MAJORITY LATINO-
AND WE HAVE VERY FEW LATINOS IN
THIS INDUSTRY- AND I WOULD LIKE
TO WORK WITH YOU TO MAKE SURE
THAT THAT IS NOT THE CASE IN
THE FUTURE- AND THAT WE
CONTINUE TO WORK TOWARDS THOSE
pADDED AS A CO AUTHOR TO THIS
BILL AND I DEFINITELY
SUPPORTING TODAY- THANK YOU FOR
YOUR WORK. ON THESE AND ISSUES.
S. MISTER MERION TO CHECK
SOMETHING SO JUSTIN A KEEP A
HUNDRED HERE- AT IS SPUR OF ALL
CENTER THERE'S NO QUESTION THAT
I'M GONNA IT BUT I A FIND INTO
SO COLLEAGUE COMMON I JUST
WANTED TO SHOW. THE TOO QUICK
POINTS OUT FIRST OF ALL- IT I
WAS VERY OF HAVING A- IN IN
WORK N FIRST- INCENTIVE. WHICH
TOOK YEARS AND YEARS TO DO MUCH
TO THE- FRUSTRATION OF FAILED
EFFORTS OF THE ENTERTAINMENT
INDUSTRY BECAUSE- THERE WASN'T
THE INTEREST TO SUPPORT THE
INDUSTRY AND- AND AS- ONE OF
OUR COLLEAGUES WAS PREVIOUSLY
MENTIONING. AT THE INDUSTRY
STARTED LEAVING AND SO IT WAS
DURING THE LAST ECONOMIC
DOWNTURN THAT WE FINALLY. MAYBE
APPROPRIATE INVESTMENT. SO IF
WE'VE LEARNED A LESSON FROM
THAT- WHEN WE LOOK AT THE
LARGEST. BUDGET THAT WE VOTED
ON AT TWO HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE
BILLION WHICH DWARFS THE BUDGET
OF TEN YEARS AGO DURING THE
ECONOMIC DOWNTURN. THAT WAS
LESS THAN. LESS THAN HALF OF
WHAT WE HAVE NOW AND WE HAD A
SEVERE BUDGET HOLD BACK THEN.
ALL WE'VE LEARNED IS THAT THIS
IS GOING TO COME BACK AND
HAPPEN AGAIN IN A FEW YEARS SO
IT'S INVESTMENTS LIKE THIS THAT
ALLOW ARE CRITICAL- INDUSTRIES
TO SURVIVE. THOSE HORRIBLE
FURROWS THAT WE DEAL WITH SO
JUST BECAUSE WE'RE IN THE PEAK
RIGHT NOW WE SHOULD BE
EXTREMELY CAREFUL TO MAKE THE
APPROPRIATE INVESTMENTS FOR
THOSE THROWS THAT WE'RE GONNA
BE DEALING WITH SO. I
WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORT THIS-
WOULD LIKE TO JOIN YOU AS A CO
AUTHOR AS WELL AND- IF THE BILL
HASN'T BEEN MOVED YET WOULD
LIKE TO MOVE THE BILL AS WELL
WE HAVE A MOTION FROM CARILLO
AND A SECOND FROM- MISTER
NAZARIAN. I JUST WANT TO SAY A
FEW WORDS THIS TAX CREDIT- AS
IT'S BEEN STATED HAS GENERATED
SIX TIMES THE INVESTMENT AND
WHICH MAKES IT A VERY
SUCCESSFUL TAX CREDIT WE NOT
ALL OF OUR TAX CREDITS CAN. CAN
PROVE THAT. AND THIS ONE HAS. I
WANT TO THANK THE SENATOR FOR
HIS COMMITMENT AND HIS
DILIGENCE. ON THIS ISSUE I WON
I THINK- REAL FOR HER WORK ON
THE DIVERSITY PORTION EACH PART
OF THE BILL THAT YOU GUYS HAVE
WORKED ON HAS A DIRECT EFFECT
ON. MY FAMILY- IN OUR HOUSEHOLD
AT MY DAUGHTER'S FATHER. TWENTY
YEARS AGO NOW I REMEMBER HIM
WORKING IN LOS ANGELES ALL THE
TIME HE WAS HOME ALL THE TIME
OR IS THIS YEAR. HE'S BEEN HOME
LESS THAN TWENTY DAYS MISSING
HIS DAUGHTER'S SEVENTH
BIRTHDAY. SO THAT HE COULD WORK
BECAUSE OTHER STATES HAVE
PULLED THEM BUSINESS AWAY FROM
CALIFORNIA- SO FOR MY DAUGHTER.
AND FOR MYSELF AND FOR HER
FATHER WHO STOOD IN MY GARAGE
CRYING OUT A WEEK AGO THAT HE
HAS NOT SEEN AS CHILD ENOUGH
BECAUSE OF WORK. I WANT TO
THANK YOU. I WOULD ALSO
RECOMMEND THAT FOR SOME OF
THESE OTHER TAX CREDIT SO WE
HAVE TALKED ABOUT THAT WE
HAVEN'T YOU KNOW THAT WE HAVE
TO DISCUSS I WOULD ENCOURAGE
THEM TO ALSO IMPLORE AND MAYBE
TALK TO MR CREEL ABOUT CREATING
A DIVERSITY PORTION OF THOSE.
TAX CREDITS AS WELL. I THINK IT
WOULD BEHOOVE THEM. WITH THAT
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE CENTER
YES THANK YOU ARE MADAM CHAIR
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS
AND- YOU KNOW HOW MUCH I THINK
OF YOUR DAUGHTER AS WELL AND I
THINK FORMER NEIGHBOR- I DO
WANNA GIVE A SHOUT OUT TO MS
RIVAS AND MISTER NAZARIAN WHO
HAVE ALSO WORKED- OVER THE
YEARS ON THIS ISSUE- A FURTHER
REASONS- THAT THEY STATED- AND
I WOULD LIKE TO MAKE A COMMENT
ON ON THE BIG PICTURE TAX
INCENTIVE. ISSUE OF THERE'S
ONLY THREE THINGS YOU CAN DO TO
THE BUCKET YOU CAN PUT MORE IN
IT YOU CAN TAKE MORE OUT OF IT
OR YOU CAN CREATE A BIGGER
BUCKET AND CLEARLY THE
INVESTMENTS THAT YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT WE NEED TO DO MORE OF-
WHEN WE DO NEED TO HAVE A BIG
PICTURE A VIEW OF CALIFORNIA'S
ECONOMIC RECOVERY IN
CALIFORNIA'S LONG TERM SUCCESS-
AND YOU KNOW SIGNED ME UP FOR
THOSE CONVERSATIONS AS WELL
BECAUSE I THINK THAT'S THAT'S
CRITICAL- AND IT'S LONG BEEN A
FRUSTRATION. IN THE LEGISLATURE
IS THAT THE WAY WE'VE LOOKED AT
TAX INCENTIVES WE ALWAYS LOOK
AT THEM AS AN EXPENDITURE NOT
AS THE INVESTMENT THAT THEY'RE
INTENDED TO BE ONE THING WE CAN
ALSO LOOK IN IS HOW WE HOW WE
BUDGET YOU KNOW CAN WE USE THE
PROJECTIVE INCOME. AS A AS A
DEDICATED REVENUE STREAM YOU
KNOW WE SHOULD LOOK AT THOSE
THOSE ISSUES SO I THINK THOSE
ARE VERY VERY IMPORTANT POINTS
THAT- THE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
MULTIPLE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS HAVE
BATES SELF- CERTAINLY WANT TO
GIVE THAT CONVERSATION IF IT'S
DUE THE OTHER PIECE THAT'S
EXCITING ABOUT THE
ENTERTAINMENT TAX CREDIT IS THE
ACCOUNTABILITY YOU ACTUALLY
HAVE TO CREATE THE JOBS YEAH
ACTUALLY HAVE TO DO THE WORK
OFTENTIMES- IN THE EARLY TWO
THOUSANDS BEFORE WE HAD PROP
TWENTY FIVE. TAX CREDITS WERE
USED AS A VEHICLE TO CLOSE TO
GET VOTES TO CLOSE THE BUDGET
DISCUSSIONS AND THERE IS VERY
LITTLE ACCOUNTABILITY IN THAT
THERE WAS VERY LITTLE- FOLLOW
UP TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY WERE
IN TE JOBS THAT WERE INTENDED
TO BE CREATED WERE ACTUALLY
CREATED AND THAT GAVE THE TAX
INCENTIVES HISTORICALLY A BAD
NAME BECAUSE THERE WAS NO
ACCOUNTABILITY THIS PARTICULAR
TAX CREDIT- FOOT THAT AND
BROUGHT THE ACCOUNT ABILITY.
THE JUDGE CREATION THE RECORD
HAD TO BE THERE IN ORDER FOR
THE MONEY TO BE DISHED OUT AND
I THINK THAT'S THAT'S AN
APPROACH THAT AS WE LOOK AT TAX
POLICY WE SHOULD LOOK AT. THAT
THAT APPROACH TO MAKING SURE
THAT THE JOBS ACTUALLY GET
CREATED THE ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT- ACTUALLY. ACTUALLY
HAPPENS AND SO. I THINK THAT AS
IS IMPORTANT AND THAT'S ALSO.
ANOTHER PIECE OF WHY THIS IS
ALSO. A SIGNIFICANT IS THE SAME
COLD FIRM. FOR THE INCENTIVES
ON DIVERSITY IN ORDER TO GET
THE ACTUAL DOLLARS. YOU HAVE TO
HAVE THOSE DIVERSITY PLANTS-
AND SO I THINK THAT'S A
CRITICAL COMPONENT WHERE
THERE'S A IMBEDDED INTO THIS.
THE ACCOUNTABILITY THAT ARE.
TAXPAYERS WANT. AND THE JOB
CREATION AND THE DIVERSITY
CREATION THAT THAT. THE SOCIETY
AND SOCIOLOGY DEMANDS THAT WE
DO- THE LAST THING I WANT TO
COVER IS. WE WOULD NOT BE HERE
OBVIOUSLY BOTH THE SENATE AND
THE ASSEMBLY WORK COLLABORATIVE
LEE TOGETHER. BUT THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WERE
STRONG SUPPORTERS OF THIS AS
WELL. THE GOVERNOR WRECKED
RECOGNIZED EARLY ON HOW
IMPORTANT THIS INDUSTRY IS TO
CALIFORNIA. AND WAS- VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF MAKING SURE WE
HAD SOMETHING IN PLACE. THAT
HAD THE ACCOUNTABILITY AND
THAT'S WHERE FINANCED CAME IN
AND HAD THE SAFEGUARDS THAT. MR
CORK MENTIONED EARLIER- THAT WE
DON'T FIND OURSELVES IN
OVERPRESCRIBE. SITUATION SO.
THE ADMINISTRATION WAS VERY
IMPORTANT TO BRING THAT FISCAL.
RESTRAINT INTO THE CONVERSATION
BUT ON A MACRO SENSE ALSO
RECOGNIZED HOW IMPORTANT THIS
INDUSTRY IS FOR CALIFORNIA. AND
WAS CENTRAL TO THE SUCCESS THAT
WE HAVE HERE SO AT A TIME WHEN
WE WATCH THE DYSFUNCTION. IN
WASHINGTON WE SAW THE TWO
HOUSES AND THE ADMINISTRATION
WORKED VERY COLLABORATIVE LEE-
TO GET US TO THIS POINT AND
THAT'S WHY WE'RE HERE SO- WITH
THAT I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISS
HOLLY TO CALL THE ROLL PLEASE
BURKE HI THE MOTION IS TO PASS
BURKE HI. BIRTH BY. WHEN
NAZARIAN HI NAZARIAN I GRAYSON.
GRAYSON I CARILLO. REAL ALL
RIGHT. CALDERON I CALDERON HI
MULLIN. MULLIN I PETRIE-NORRIS
PETRIE-NORRIS- A QUIRK HI I
RIVAS. RIVAS I'D SAY OUR TELL.
NINE NINE ZERO ITSELF THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SENATOR. YEAH I HAVE.
WITH THAT WE ARE ADJOURNED.